From breathtaking action sequences
that are arguably better than those
in the first film to the continued
use of tired and harmful tropes,
here are the 6 best and 6 worst things
about "Avatar: The Way of Water" ranked.
James Cameron is well-known for being at the
forefront of advancing the tech behind visual
effects in film, especially with regards to using
computer-generated images — or CGI. While there
have been computer-generated visual effects in
films going as far back as 1973 with the original
"Westworld", Cameron is famous for continuing to
push the technology further with each successive
project. For instance, in 1989's "The Abyss,"
Cameron used — at the time — state-of-the-art
CGI to create the now-famous "water tentacle"
with digitally-mapped 3D faces of the actors.
He then created the first partially-CG main
character in Robert Patrick's liquid metal T-1000
form in "Terminator 2: Judgment Day," and later
pushed the tech once more in 2009's "Avatar."
It must be said that the CGI in "Avatar: The Way
of Water" is indeed pretty impressive. While the
visuals in the original "Avatar" were cutting
edge at the time, they — like a lot of CGI
effects in films before it — have shown their age
a bit. However, the advancement in visual effects
technology between the first "Avatar" and "The Way
of Water" is palpable. It's especially noticeable
when the film focuses on the Na'vi's facial
features, or anything involving the physics
of water. Not only that, but there are many
effects-heavy scenes in the film, which — coupled
with filming in a higher frame rate — makes
it feel like you're literally on Pandora.
Despite the previously mentioned moments of
special effects greatness, there are also some
VFX shots that were obviously given more care
than others. Despite a long-gestating 13-year
gap between "Avatar: The Way of Water" and
the original "Avatar," there's still not an
infinite amount of time to design, plan, and
render each shot — especially for a film that
is mostly CG-animated. This is all exacerbated
by the fact that director James Cameron insisted
on creating new tech specifically for
the film, but also meant that research
and development for the new tech inevitably cut
into rendering times for the individual shots.
This is not to mention the lack of unionization
in the VFX industry that leads to artist burn-out,
fast turnarounds, and outsourcing some
shots to VFX houses offering the lowest bid,
rather than the best quality. This
is admittedly an industry-wide issue,
and not just relegated to "Avatar: The Way of
Water" — but still. It needs to be mentioned.
James Cameron has had a prolific career as an
A-list director, and one of the main things
he's known for is his amazing action scenes. Even
his epic period drama "Titanic" — which focused
most of its three-hour-plus runtime on a budding
romance — still had an intense, pulse-pounding
40-minute climax, featuring some of the best
action sequences in cinema history to this day.
"Ahhhhhhh!"
"Avatar: The Way of Water" is no exception.
There are so many great action set pieces in
the film that rival, and arguably
surpass, the 2009 original. This
includes an exciting futuristic train
heist near the beginning of the film,
a scene where the evil RDA corporation chases
down a herd of the sentient whale-like tulkun,
and the climax on the ocean where Jake Sully
leads his family and the marine-based Metkayina
tribe against a newly-resurrected
Colonel Quaritch and his gang.
The finale in particular is a
really breathtaking sequence,
and showcases why Cameron is the top of the
game in terms of action genre cinema. The
blocking is clear and precise, the spatial
orientation is always legible, and there's
no overuse of either shaky-cam or the overdone
Zack Snyder-esque slow-down/ramp-up technique.
James Cameron is no stranger to
having long runtimes for his films.
1997's "Titanic," for instance, was
three hours and 14 minutes. Even the
original "Avatar" wasn't anemic either,
with a two-hour and 41-minute runtime.
While "Avatar: The Way of Water" may not be the
longest film in Cameron's career — clocking in
at three hours and 12 minutes — it's still one
of the longest mainstream Hollywood films in
recent memory, with only "Avengers: Endgame"
coming close at a minute over three hours.
This is not to say that long runtimes are
inherently bad — far from it. This year's
blockbuster Tollywood period action-adventure
film "RRR" ran for three hours and seven minutes,
and is one of 2022's most financially and
critically successful films worldwide.
However, "RRR," along with most of the
three-hour-plus epics from decades past,
at least had intermissions, which is not the
case for modern theatrical films. To be fair,
James Cameron has suggested seeing the movie
multiple times if going to the bathroom is
a problem ... though that seems to be a
solution that's more than a bit self-serving.
Whatever critics might say about the
quality — or lack thereof — concerning
the visual effects in "Avatar: The Way of
Water," the art direction on the film is
at least consistently phenomenal regardless.
Honestly, the style of the film truly evokes
the aesthetic of the old Lisa Frank Trapper
Keepers from the '80s and '90s — and that's
a good thing. The film is just so full of
vibrant, saturated, and bright colors that
nothing else that has come out in cinemas
for the last few years looks quite like it.
The production design is frankly next level,
and stands head-and-shoulders above a lot
of other big-budget sci-fi films of the same
caliber. There's almost no comparison to the
amount of detail that James Cameron has put
into building every single nook and cranny
of Pandora. This includes the idyllic coastal
Metkayinan villages and the militaristic RDA
corporate facility that contrasts greatly with the
naturalistic Pandoran landscape surrounding it.
The various cool and exotic alien creatures in
the sequel are often a sight to behold as well,
in particular the sentient whale-like
tulkuns, or the "skimwing," creatures
that the Metkayinan Na'vi tribe ride which are
similar to the flying ikran from the first film.
One of the biggest issues with
the first "Avatar" was the story's
inherent "white savior" issue. While pretty
self-explanatory, the term "white savior"
refers to an extremely outdated — and arguably
white supremacist — narrative trope in fiction,
where a white person joins a group of marginalized
people, and instantly becomes the best of them.
This fits the story of the
original "Avatar" to a tee,
as a white man named Jake Sully becomes part of
the Indigenous-coded alien Na'vi tribe on Pandora,
and ends up not only being the best of them,
but also literally becoming their leader.
To be clear, this is not to say that "Avatar" is
intentionally hateful or anything like that. But
it's not great when the film nonetheless
reinforces harmful narrative tropes like
"the white savior" and "the noble savage,"
which fit the depiction of the Na'vi as well.
Unfortunately, "Avatar: The Way of Water"
does little to alleviate these problems,
and in fact compounds them. Jake ends up
leading an attack on the humans with not
just his own family, but also commanding the
literal king of the Metkayina Na'vi tribe as
well. His negligent actions also lead directly
to the devastation of many Metkayina villages,
which never amounts to much in
the way of consequences for him.
James Cameron is known for making some of
the best sequels of all time, whether it's
following up Ridley Scott's classic sci-fi/horror
film "Alien" with one of the best sci-fi/action
flicks ever in "Aliens," or continuing his own
"Terminator" tale with "Terminator 2: Judgment
Day," that somehow made Arnold Schwarzenegger's
deadly Terminator loveable enough to cry over.
"Why the hell'd you do that?"
"Because you told me to."
In both cases, Cameron was able to find a way
to turn those original stories on their heads,
but also made sure that what made those
films work in the first place remained
intact — such as keeping the xenomorphs scary,
or letting both "Terminator" films be explosive,
bloody, and thrilling. The same
goes for "Avatar: The Way of Water."
Cameron keeps what worked in the first
film — the amazingly-rendered environments,
the anti-corporate message, and the deep
spiritual mythology — and adds some new,
much-appreciated wrinkles. One of the most
narratively satisfying additions to the
sequel is the inclusion of the Metkayina clan, an
aquatic-based Na'vi tribe living on the beaches
near Pandora's oceans. The initial tension
between Jake and the Metakayina, as well as
a sense that the Na'vi tribes have long-standing
prejudices against each other, makes the world
feel much more real and nuanced. It also raises
the stakes by making fighting off the humans that
much harder, which also reflects Indigenous
struggles against colonization in our world.
Stephen Lang is a great actor. In many of his
roles, he's able to effortlessly exude extreme
intensity and menace, including his performance as
"Avatar" main antagonist Colonel Miles Quaritch.
"You crossed the line."
In that first film, Quaritch thematically
represents the military arm of capitalistic
imperialism, as the massive corporation
RDA contracts the Earth military to aid
in Pandora's colonization — which is
based around wiping out or enslaving
the native Na'vi population to ease efforts
in exploiting the planet's special resource,
unobtainium. Lang does a great job in the
role: he's just the right mix of arrogant,
strong-willed, and scary to be a
worthy adversary for the heroes.
However, he's also a bit one-dimensional.
It's fine for the story that "Avatar" tells,
which is more about Jake Sully discovering
and learning to love Pandora and the Na'vi;
it makes sense that more screen time and
narrative real estate is given to that plotline,
rather than developing Quaritch as a character.
But unlike fun or interesting villains like
Loki or Hannibal Lecter, Quaritch is just not
compelling enough to bring back. As written,
he was always just a stereotypical military guy.
To be fair, Cameron does attempt to add layers
to Quaritch in "Avatar: The Way of Water" —
particularly his relationship to his left-behind
son, Spider. Still though, even that's hacky and
cliché in its own way, hearkening back to the fact
that so many villains have daddy issues already.
Like any good spectacle-filled action epic, there
are a lot of applause-worthy moments sprinkled
throughout "Avatar: The Way of Water." However,
none are as crowd-pleasing as the scene where a
banished tulkun — a massive, sentient whale-like
creature that is a vital part of Metkayina
culture — jumps out of the ocean to completely
decimate an RDA-funded tulkun-hunting vessel.
Honestly, the banished tulkun character – who
is befriended by Jake Sully's youngest son,
Lo'ak — is a highlight of the film in general.
The bond that forms between Lo'ak and the banished
tulkun has all the hallmarks of a classic "A
Boy and His X" story, but done extremely well.
The subplot takes its time to tease out
the banished tulkun's tragic backstory,
as Lo'ak initially discovers the
tulkun covered in injuries with
remnants of Earth tech embedded in its
hide. The film's extended runtime also
allows for the tulkun and Lo'ak's
deep friendship to grow naturally,
and makes the tulkun's redemption in helping the
Na'vi fight the humans that much more satisfying.
As an actress, Sigourney Weaver is a
nerdy fan-favorite, starring in many
classic sci-fi genre staples over the
years such as "Galaxy Quest," all but
one "Ghostbusters" film, and — of course —
as Ellen Ripley in the "Alien" franchise.
Weaver returned to star in Cameron's "Avatar"
in 2009, where she plays Dr. Grace Augustine,
a highly-regarded xenobotanist on
Pandora who is also the head of the
"Avatar Program" that puts human minds
into Na'vi bodies. Dr. Augustine is also
sympathetic to Pandora and the Na'vi,
unlike a lot of her human colleagues.
"You need to listen to what she says. You
need to see the forest through her eyes."
Unfortunately, she dies before the end of the
first film, after an attempt to resurrect her
at the Tree of Souls fails. Surprisingly,
like Lang, Weaver returns in "Avatar:
The Way of Water." However, unlike Lang, Weaver
returns as a new Na'vi character named Kiri,
the adopted teen daughter of Jake Sully and
Neytiri. Unfortunately, despite her best efforts,
Weaver playing a teenager is simply too
distracting to work. Weaver, of course,
is an amazing actress, but it's still not
enough to hide the fact that she is starring
alongside actual young adults as her siblings.
Though her Na'vi form looks like a young,
blue Sigourney Weaver, the voice doesn't, and it
comes off as unsettling more than anything else.
Whatever James Cameron's faults are as a
storyteller, his lack of subtlety is not one
of them. Say what you will about "Avatar,"
but the themes of anti-capitalism are very
clear and well-defined in that film. The
audience unambiguously witnesses the violent,
devastating effects that careless,
untethered capitalistic greed has on
the beauty and balance of nature, and how
its lust for infinite growth also leads to
the genocide of entire cultures, like the
Na'vi — or Indigenous tribes in real life.
This anti-capitalist messaging is thankfully
maintained in "Avatar: The Way of Water." In fact,
that message is expanded upon in the new film.
We find out that there's a whole operation run
by the RDA, where they round up and slaughter
entire families of tulkun simply to extract a
single vial of brain fluid. Meanwhile, the corpse
of the whale-sized creature is left to rot in
the ocean. This is reminiscent of the wasteful
and inhumane whaling practices on Earth today.
One of the best characters from the original
"Avatar" film was the proud and strong Na'vi
warrior Neytiri, with Zoe Saldaña of "Guardians
of the Galaxy" fame doing the vocal and motion
capture performance for her. In fact, Neytiri's
beauty, strength, and bravery are the main reasons
that Sam Worthington's Jake Sully switches
sides, deciding to protect the Na'vi from
the invading human army. She is Jake's — and
the audience's — guide to the wondrous world
of Pandora, and her and Jake's love story is
the emotional crux of the entire first film.
"But this woman must also choose me."
"She already has."
Unfortunately, in "Avatar: The Way of Water,"
Saldaña's Neytiri is pretty much sidelined
for most of the film's arduous runtime. She
mostly plays the cliché role of the concerned
wife and mother, usually in the background
fretting while Jake and her children get to
do all the narrative heavy lifting. There
are even some very uncomfortable moments
when Jake forcefully shuts her up after
she brings up valid complaints. Yikes.
To be fair, the sequel shifts the focus
away from Jake as well, since the story
is a generational one about their kids, instead
of them. But Jake still gets a lot more to do
in "The Way of Water," while in the first one,
Neytiri and Jake's importance to the overall
narrative was much more equal. Also, while it's
true that Neytiri gets to be an awesome warrior
during the climax, it's also kind of a "too
little, too late" situation at that point.